Pamela utu watched her 19-year-old
nephew being HED to death and her home
burned down the attackers said they were
from the armed group Al shabab several
other people who lived in this Village
near bony forest in lamo County were
also murdered in June even
now I feel very bad because I saw the K
slaughtered he was breathing like a
bull
slaughtered Samuel chomba is buried here
he was also killed on that day in
June these are not isolated cases
security forces are struggling to deal
with the fighters who are sa to be
hiding in the forest they've carried out
attacks on civilians and sec security
Personnel the government launched a
military offensive against al chabab in
2015 that's
ongoing State officials say some gains
have been made but the forest is vast
thick and extends to the border with
Somalia it's a very very organized group
that can carry out
uh such Breen attacks on our on our
menro unless we place Security in every
Homestead it is also quite a challenge
even for the security to provide
adequate security the worst attack
happened 9 years ago more than 50 people
were killed in a town near the
forest these are names of people who
were killed in an attack in the town of
peeton in 2014 Al shabab claimed that
attack and we've been talking to
relatives who come here often to pay
their respects we've also been talking
to villagers who leave in other areas
farther away and they say they continue
to live in fear because attacks there
are still
ongoing so now Pamela utu and her
neighbors sleep rough in this
school most of the 2,000 or so people
who called this place home have fled to
other are
they say until they feel safe enough
they won't come back Katherine soy alaz
lamu County
Kenya